I just wanted to get your brain back in
the mood after a weekend of thinking in
Exponential's logs turn back and forth
between them and also remembering some
of your long-lost actually whether you
got to the end of those four questions
is less interesting to me than whether
you actually engage with them and we're
able to pull on those neurons that have
all that stuff in there because we're
going to need that big time today okay
let's have a look from the top and we'll
go through these relatively quickly
because I think most of you're getting a
sense of it now when you've got a
question like three to the power of some
unknown number and then it equals a
number that's not like a nice neat power
like if the right-hand side said nine
through the power of something is nine
you could instantly say oh that's three
squared equals nine right or if it was
27 or 81 if it were a nice number but I
deliberately gave you a gross number
because that's where our knowledge of
logs and Exponential's can actually help
so I can rewrite this first equation in
a form that makes K this subject makes K
equals something and then I can work out
what that is
how do I do that how do I rewrite it
yeah go ahead string cool okay so what
we've done is same numbers k 3 100 we
just rearranged it and trains put them
all in exactly the right spots now this
is true and it's better because now I've
got a K equals but I need to change the
base because I don't have a base 3
button on the calculator I've got a base
10 button got a base a button either of
them is fine how do I actually change
the base you can use your reference
sheet there yeah okay got it
tell us what you
log base 10 of 100 divided by log base
10 of 3 are we happy with that I check
out it does and you could have done base
E or you could dump base 5 or any base
you likes long as it's the same on the
top of the bottom this is good because
the calculators got this button as long
as you have 100 and your 3 are in the
right spots and conveniently at least
the way I remembered it is in the
original expression and 100 on the top
so it's going to end up well it's
trending up question will you those
marks if for example you wrote this yeah
is this what you're asking okay so
whenever I get asked a question about
like will I lose marks or will I get
marks for whatever right I always
hesitate because I can't always in most
cases I kind of give like a this is
always what will happen right because it
sort of depends on how much is the
question worth what's the question
really assessing is this like the whole
question or is this on the way to doing
some other thing like is this part of a
small part of it right my initial
instinct to say actually that's probably
fine because sometimes you see it
written there in fact normally if you
say written in a question or in a
textbook this right what base do you
think is imply there has to be a base
what do you think the base is now in a
textbook or in a test this is sneaky
right pretty much anywhere except for
one exception I will tell you in a
second anyway you see it with no base
it's implying a which I know is a bit
weird because there is a single place a
place you use a lot that doesn't mean
that where's the place that doesn't mean
that you've got it right in front of you
it's your calculator we're talking about
as before but I'll refresh your memory
why is it that on your calculator it's
actually back to what we were suggesting
before why is our calculator say L og
with no base use base 10 because your
calculator is a particular kind of
calculator to remember phone
it's a scientific calculator scientific
calculators are useful for what kind of
notation scientific notation which has a
base of Tim okay so that's why it's
there the reason why I think it's sort
of flying either way is because well if
it's the same base on the top of the
bottom that's what makes change of base
law work did someone get a number and in
this moment sorry are we gonna ask
another question oh yeah please
4.19 yeah go ahead well if it is just
long do we have to assume that it is
baby say oh I'll just just for clarity
just for clarity I'll say it one more
time anywhere in the world that we're
doing maths and UCL oh gee with no base
right except on your calculator it means
basically it's part of why you know we
actually we do differentiation with
explanations expenditures logs and we
focus on a and not other bases because
that's where all the interesting maths
kind of happens right so we get to other
bases a separate thing which is what
we're doing today but everywhere else
you can assume it's a-okay and don't
forget by the way I asked you to
approximate and please say that you do
because it isn't actually exactly 4.19
it's roughly okay happy times can we
have a look at the second one we should
be able to do this a bit quicker because
you sort of used the same skill that we
used before we can't tell you yeah sort
of I went from an exponential equation
to a log equation here and I want to go
in the opposite directions so what
should I write first okay so I've got
the question once I've written the
question yep how do i how do I start to
reformat K equals where are we going to
a minute good for to the power of two
and a half which you could pop straight
into your calculator hopefully it gives
you a number but I'm just going to say
as well that hopefully your brain also
has your index laws in there as well and
these this you don't even need a
calculator for all this I mean your
calculator is nice to confirm it but
four squared of course is 16 and for the
power of 1/2 that's actually for the
power of 1/2 what does it mean when
you've got a fraction in the index
that's a square root isn't it so that's
actually the square root of 4 which is 2
which gave you the answer your
calculator probably already told you
which was 32 is that okay can I just
quickly rather than worry about them
working for these can I just give the
answers for three and four just so we
can confirm and I can see if anyone's
got problems Edison or if you got for
three 1.76 can I please get some
agreement or disagreement on that okay
I've got two nods great did you only
give me the last one
3.32
and we also similarly happily happily
with that yep okay and by the way does
it fit does it fit
or do we have it wait that different
that's what yeah throw one six hold on
that's a bit off
who got three point three two a couple
of hands took a few hands okay so we're
gonna have to sort this out who've got
three point one six I want to see the
hands again okay shinb Ovid yours can we
walk through how you did it
can you walk us through some wedding
[Music]
three point three two or three point one
six I'm interested people who've got the
other answer did you have this as a line
of working because I feel like this
should give something unambiguous out of
the calculator have we checked it again
yeah are you witchy three one six we're
happy okay so we'll get rid of this I'm
interested where 3.32 came from now I'm
like is that just a stuff of calculator
button when your fingers are to stop you
for this calculator okay you're not
getting it when you put in the square
root of 10 is this what you're wondering
that you're wondering how we got to the
square root n okay let's um let's wind
back for a second session Bobby said K
squared equals 10 are we happy with that
line yes no you're like kind of you're
looking really like you're not impressed
okay so let's have a look here we're
converting a log equation into an
exponential right the way that I
remember it is always that the base down
here comes from the base over here when
you go back and forth between an
exponential and a log the bases will
stay the same so you get base here base
here base here turns into this base over
here and then even though it's sort of a
crass way of thinking about all the rest
of the numbers they just kind of swap
sides you see how K and 10 are together
in the log equation or K and 2 will be
together in the exponential equation so
if you did you're asked a question
yeah you got this as well can you tell
me Tommy three let me get another color
they're here can you talk me through how
you get for a second let me catch up
with you is that what you just said
that's on your left-hand side equals two
okay cool go ahead
[Music]
okay so let me see if I'm under so if
you're right what she's done here this
fraction is the same change of base that
we use right at the top yet you remember
that right from the beginning so she's
chosen 10 it's actually a really good
choice because I gave you a number which
is on your calculator when she goes
through and divides through by two
that's gonna end up up in the power just
like we did here okay but thankfully log
base something of something go back this
is like a basic log all right log base
five and five a log base 800 of 800
what's that equal to
that's one isn't it so that's ten to the
power of 1/2 equals K which actually is
equivalent to this which is why we get
the same answer that we got before even
though it's quite a different part okay
make more lines nice I'm pretty happy
with that well done okay